So now you've saved a lot of words,
created LingQs, you've saved, I hope,
phrases and you're probably wondering
how you can possibly review all of these
words? The good news is you don't have to
review them all. In fact, if you're
creating a lot of LingQs, as I always do,
I can't possibly review them all. You
review some of them. You can review them
after each page when you're reading, you
can go to the vocabulary page and select
a different group of words to review, you
can choose which of the different
activities you want to use, you know
flashcards, multiple-choice, dictation,
reverse flash cards. It's more an
opportunity to increase your
attentiveness to the language, especially
if you create tags. Even creating tags
focuses your attention on these words
and phrases. But don't think you can
review them all, you can't. Review some of
them and spend most of your time
enjoyably listening and reading and
seeing all of your LingQs show up in
yellow and eventually they turn to white.